this is what the mayfield candle factory
looked like before the storm this is
what it looks like now
i saw on site
a backpack
that was left behind in a pair of shoes
and it represents uh the tragedy
that this uh tornado has wreaked
uh on this area of kentucky
we learned of a telephone uh that was
recovered a cell phone that recorded 27
missed messages
we've lost
fathers mothers
brothers
sisters
sons daughters
and others
teams from department of homeland
security and the federal emergency
management agency or fema are now on the
scene but the likelihood of finding more
survivors diminishes by the hour
friday's tornado destroyed everything it
touched in mayfield this used to be the
historic town center now it is leveled
that was once a doctor's office
back there churches now nothing but
rubble
this trailer was picked up in the sky
and dropped here like a toy and people's
personal belongings from their homes
their photographs of their family
members now litter the streets
david hargrove digs through what remains
of his law office volunteers are helping
him recover client files he didn't
expect to also find this
i've had this desk for since my
daughter's been born
and you know things they draw for you
and i had it under a glass
and that's the
i found most of that
there's still no power or running water
but the recovery work is in full swing
ten thousand people call this town home
i can't even tell what's what right now
because it's all piled up it's like like
a war zone that happened here
and
it's unreal
words can't describe what i feel right
now
of my hometown
the loss of life here is the greatest
shock
knowing some of the rune homes belong to
the factory workers who will never
return hearts are heavy as the cleanup
continues heidi joe castro al jazeera
mayfield kentucky